bon
[Musique]
tous talents tous contes et histoires
des aventures
aventure jalons vous conter l'histoire
les aventures de renault
ce jour is andré renard et le chemin
la fois
en fin d'échangés
oui ça
gagnant sera bouffe nam
[Musique]
te voilà neuf ans tu me laisses eux
seuls sont avertir que la trouille avait
été rebouché tu m'as trahi à bay hill en
gras ce n'est pas moi qui n'ai remous
chez c'est ce méchant prêtre moi aussi
j'ai dû fuir sous ces menaces mais je
vous attendais inquiet sous ce chêne si
nous allions vendre ses habits à la fois
bonnes idées mon compteur
yeves hoegaarden seigneur vous aussi mon
père
d'où venez vous ainsi nous sommes des
marchands nous allons à la foire nous
fournissons les chanoines de l'église
toute proche
mais bien sûr nous pourrions vous donner
la préférence
combien mendier vous aime bien et j'irai
droit au but donnez moi c'est toi et
nous habitons pas vous le marché me
semble honnête c'est d'accord
[Musique]
dommage que nous n'ayons pas une
deuxième mois car tu n'es pas aussi bien
partagée que moi voulez vous dire que
vous gardez loi pour vous tout seul
ce serait une bien mauvaise action
ysengrin
[Musique]
je n'ai pas besoin de serment si tu
souffres de la fin tu trouvera de quoi
l'apaiser dans ce bois
[Musique]
moi
où
m
oh
[Musique]
et
on